in the world of Moana there are
definitely gods and demigods but have
you ever thought that Moana could be one
of them
stay tuned to see what about mallanna's
past has us thinking that she could be a
demigod now on to the secret history of
mallanna
we were voyagers if you've seen the
movie Moana then you know there is a lot
to unpack here and if you haven't seen
the movie then we fully give you
permission to pause this video go back
and watch the movie and then come back
and restart this video is filled with
tons of spoilers and some serious
mallanna geeking out so it's probably
best that you see the film before
watching this video okay
now that only those of us who have
actually seen the film are here let's
get started so you know that in the
world of Moana there are gods and
demigods demigods look pretty much like
humans and walk the earth like the rest
of us the only difference is that those
gods have powers that normal humans do
not the powers of each demigod differ
depending on a number of factors after
watching the movie some fans wondered if
Moana herself was actually a demigod
they look like normal humans right check
Milan it definitely looks like a normal
human so why not explore this idea
further first we need to know what
exactly demigods are and the history
behind them before we can jump into if
Moana is part of this mystical group of
creatures the first people came to
Polynesia about two thousand years ago
most of these people came from Southeast
Asia when they migrated they brought
along all of their traditions and ideas
about deities and gods but as time went
on the people would spread out among the
islands and each group began to come up
with their own way of thinking and own
beliefs about deities the stories about
deities began to fit each groups
environment all of these groups are
really into nature they valued becoming
really good at navigation and mastering
the ocean they believed that everyone
and everything had a source of power
running through it called mana mana
could be both good and evil they
believed that all people animals and
objects had differing amounts of mana in
them the Polynesians also believe that
mana was secret because of this belief
they created rules to protect mana for
instance regular people were not allowed
to touch the shadow of a chief they also
couldn't go into temples either
if you broke one of these rules it was
bad news the punishment was usually some
kind of bodily harm they also believe
that sickness and bad luck would come on
to you if you work hot breaking amana
ruled from this belief came the creation
of the demigods you've been told all our
people's stories but one unlike other
religions the Polynesian people felt
very close to their demigods these
demigods had flaws just like people but
had supernatural abilities they were
tricksters who liked to get their own
ways but they were still beloved by all
the people who believed in them the most
popular demigod in this culture was Maui
which was probably why he made it into
the movie he was known as being a small
man but being super powerful nonetheless
as history goes on he is said to have
created the Pacific Islands with his
magic hook and also to have given humans
more hours of sunlight by slowing down
the sun's rotation in the sky in the
ancient tales Maui was not immortal he
tried to become immortal but failed the
Polynesians would worship Maui and other
gods through chants and prayers they
would also have rituals and perform
sacrifices to show the gods their
devotion magic spells could also be used
to bring the gods out and ask them for
help there's nothing in Polynesian
history that says that new demigods
can't be created as time goes on so it
is plausible that Moana could be one as
well let's jump into a couple things
that make us think that Moana could
possibly be a demigod just like Maui the
first is that she was able to follow
Maui into laloux ty now this is the
realm of monsters theoretically no
normal human should be able to walk in
there unless they have passed on now he
was able to waltz in there because he's
a demigod but what about Moana the long
drop to get into Lola tai should have
really taken Moana out on its own but
she lands and is just fine our
conspiracy theorist Gaming duelist 15
thought this was especially strange so
he did some research on the history of
Lola Tai and found out that it was
originally described as a place for
ancestral spirits aka the underworld how
would a mere human like Moana be able to
just traipse through the underworld
unscathed the answer is that she
wouldn't be able to she would have to be
a demigod to be able to do that
went even further down the rabbit hole
and discovered that in Polynesian
history the real name for the underworld
is below - hello - was said to be
invisible to mortals which meant that
they could never get there because they
wouldn't be able to see it this alone
proves that Moana could not have just
been a mere mortal another reason why we
are seriously doubting that Moana is an
ordinary human is that she sees people
who have passed on that's not normal at
all after Moe Ana's grandmother passes
away she sees her everywhere I don't
know about you but we've never seen a
ghost just walking around and if we did
see a ghost we definitely wouldn't be at
half as calm about it as mallanna was in
other movies when people see ghosts it's
a clear indicator that something is
wrong but for some reason when most
people saw this happening in Moana no
one thought anything was weird another
reason why Moana can't be human is
pretty obvious the girl is impervious to
getting hurt seriously things that
should harm a normal person don't even
faze her there are a number of times in
the film that Moana is overcome by water
there are also a few scenes where she's
underwater for a ridiculously long time
but instead of drowning like any normal
person she pops back up like nothing
happened what human can survive
underwater like she can is she a mermaid
or something and even if she were a
mermaid that would still make her a sort
of demigod wouldn't it if that isn't
enough to convince you let's look at
another time that she was hurt the first
time that she tried to sail her boat
beyond the reef her boat was flipped
over she got knocked in the water and
her boat knocked her in the head these
things happening in quick succession
like they did should have at least
seriously injured her but no mallanna
came out of the situation unscathed just
like she does in all of the rest of them
either Moana has extremely good luck or
she obviously is immortal let's look at
Mona's family history to really drive
this point home her father is chief tui
as we mentioned previously in Polynesian
history Chiefs were seen to have a
special amount of mana so much so that
others weren't even allowed to touch
them they were seen to be a bit godly so
the only natural conclusion is that
those in the Chiefs bloodline would also
have a little bit of extra mana as well
even more than that tui and Malana share
a lot of the same attributes tui was
also called by the water in the same way
that Moana was in fact that is probably
where she got her love for the water he
also dreamed of sailing the same way
that his ancestors had when he was
younger he and his best friend went out
into a canoe into the ocean they were
able to cross the Barrier Reef
successfully but after they did they
were hit with rough waters and their
ship was destroyed during all of this -
his best friend drowned - he survived
though could this be because he's also a
god how else would - we have managed to
survive such a catastrophic event while
his friend drowned it doesn't seem
likely
I should've burned those boats a long
time ago he and Moana have a strange
ability to survive in circumstances
where anyone else would have surely been
at least injured could it be all of that
mana coursing through their veins if we
go even further down low on his family
history we get to her grandmother who is
the most godlike of anyone in the movie
Oh Tala is known to be the keeper of
ancient stories in the film why you
might think it's because she's old but
we think it's because she's ancient
herself how else would she be the only
one that knows all of the old stories
she is also super in tuned with nature
and thinks that other people cannot see
she feels that there is a growing
darkness that's threatening her home in
her people she also prophesizes that it
will be Moana who saves everyone how
would a normal person know that we know
what you're thinking how could she be a
god when she passes away well maybe she
didn't actually pass away but instead
she just changed forms before she
supposedly passes away Tala tells Moana
that she will be with her always and she
keeps her word once she passes away she
isn't really gone she's still there for
Moana whenever Moana needs her she
supports Moana and even sings with her
when she's supposed to be in the
afterlife
so tell us does that sound like she's a
normal human the theories that we have
looked at suggest that Moana was always
a demigod that like the gods in Greek
mythology she was born into her godly
status but there are other
to explore demigods don't have to be
born by a god to be mighty in the film
Maui himself is not even born a God
instead he's abandoned by his normal
parents and raised by gods in order to
become a God in Polynesian mythology
Maui is said to have been born to a god
an immortal woman which is how he became
a demigod his origin doesn't really
matter it just shows that there is more
than one way to become a god or a
demigod this next theory brought on by
redditors suggests that Moana wasn't
born a god but rather she became one
after passing away remember when we
mentioned how she somehow managed to
survive that shipwreck that occurred
when she went past the Barrier Reef well
in this theory she actually didn't
survive that crash
instead she passed away and became a God
our first clue that this could be
correct is that when she wakes up and
hears the song you're welcome this song
is all about the powers of demigods
which could be Disney trying to tell us
something if you pay close attention
you'll notice that it's after this point
in the movie that we want to starts
takes a bit
superhuman qualities for instance she
then is able to push over huge statues
she starts to see and talk to other gods
and even defeats other demigods if you
still need more convincing that Moana
becomes a god just look at Maui story
about how he became a demigod he says
that he was thrown into the ocean as a
baby but instead of the ocean overcoming
him he was saved by the gods after they
saved him the gods gave him powers and
made him a demigod this is pretty much a
mirror story to what this theories
describes happening to Moana
to make matters even more obvious she
even asked the ocean for help during
this storm a little help what if the
ocean did help her by drowning her and
then bringing her back to life as a
demigod no matter which theory you
believe it's clear that due to
mallanna's past her family background
and Polynesian history mallanna is no
normal human all of these factors come
together to prove that there is more to
Moana than meets the eye whether she's a
demigod or full-on God you can't ignore
the fact we would love to see Disney
explore this fact more in the future and
maybe
even in a sequel wouldn't you and that's
it for the secret history of Moana were
you surprised by anything in this video
let us know in the comments below thanks
for watching and see you next time
[Music]